conan you know i've been watching this
show all summer and i've got to say
you have had one hell of a summer
for me to poop on
who you got today conan and who you got
over there who you
oh
wrinkles he's got rickles
wait wait hold on everybody people i
hope you realize i hope you know
i'm all flustered this is the guy man
this is the guy who started it all
rickles he made it possible for the rest
of us i mean
this is the man for me to take a big fat
coupon
i mean come on come on
give it a rest old man look at this guy
over here i've got
chew toys that have aged better than you
wrinkles wrinkles wrinkles i had
i had the case of the wrinkles once did
the doctor walked my butt with ointment
and then it went away
ricol's over there mr mr big shot
las vegas mr humps the show girls
mr mister i opened for sinatra
oh that must have been a real treat for
the sinatra fans you know
hey folks we've got some alpo supreme
coming up for you but first you've got
to drink out of the toilet
adorable animal adorable
what the hell am i doing i'm insulting a
legend
rickles is the king
for you to poop on no
shut up you hockey puck not for me or
anyone to poop on
mr rickles please i apologize i
i they put me up to this you're the king
not for anyone
mr rickles this may be presumptuous on
my part but i would be
so honored may i sniff your butt
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry that was
inappropriate
i'm sorry i am not worthy of you
don rickles i am the drags you know what
everyone
you should poop on me yes please
go find me who
find me please wreckles i'm all ready
for you
i'm all ready i've got it all here
please poop on me
i'll see you at the pond please mr
nichols please
please
please
dog